do you remember life before smartphones
at all yeah yeah I remember it and it
just it just feels so [__] so alien
to me yeah dude I remember like when I
was like you know 10 11 years old and
you know because it's Australia yeah we
still had dial up and uh every time I
would go to my friend's house and I'd be
like yo I found this really funny
animation on Newgrounds we should watch
it and we would sit there for like three
hours as a loaded
and I'd be like uh excuse me uh uh I
need you to get off the phone right like
right now just just for like the next
two hours don't pick up a phone yeah
because I really want to show my friend
this [__] animation and the animation
would last like a minute and I'd be like
worth the wait
I I think it's really cool that we were
able to experience such a dramatic shift
in like yeah in human life oh yeah
um something that I guess I mean has
there been anything this significant in
a long time that's changed everything
it's Industrial Revolution yeah it's
insane yeah I remember like I remember
the first time
um the first time I had not experience
with an iPhone but like experiencing the
kind of like potential it had uh because
I'd I'd never I'd never been that kid
that would had like the best
Technologies not even close
um so I remember
it was 2000 it was 2008 I was 18. uh and
uh we had heard about some guy this
sounds like an episode of the
in-betweeners we had heard about this
some like a mate of a mate of a mate
yeah who was throwing this massive party
in the middle of a farm
and uh of course we were we were just
like I think you told us about this yeah
this was like the farm party where some
guy burnt down the couch yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I don't think I ever told you
the story about how we got to this part
okay okay yeah so so that was the party
how we got to this party was okay this
is like it was a farm in the middle of
but [__] nowhere right
um somewhere in like the South down
somewhere and uh I I was a designated
driver so you know didn't drink at that
party or anything I was I was a
designated designated driver because I
was the only one with a driver's license
at the time okay of course and uh at the
time uh didn't you know the iPhone just
got announced at uh 2007 so uh when I
got sent the address I was gonna be I
was busy being like okay I need to
actually note down the route to this
address yeah and one of my mate goes nah
we don't need to do that don't worry I
have this new thing it's an iPhone it's
permanently connected to Google Maps
don't worry we can find our way and I
was like you you for real we can do that
the future is now the future that's the
[__] future and he was like yeah
don't worry about this I got this so
he's like he's like directing me the
like he's like directing me the entire
way in Brighton getting how to get out
of the city and stuff I'm like holy [__]
this is the [__] future I don't
[__] I don't believe this yeah
as soon as we get just a little bit out
of the city here I'm driving down the
road and then there's a there's a cross
section coming up there's a turn coming
up but either go left or right and I go
uh this this car is like full by the way
but my mate's directing me and I go uh
do I go left or right
doesn't answer I know he goes
uh hold on a second
um yeah the the cross section is coming
out
uh do I go left or right
uh I don't know
uh it's kind of loading right now uh I
don't think we have any signal
to put things in perspective uh where
where what we think is about a 15 to 20
minute drive from the place uh where we
are right now there are no Street lamps
there are no lights it is Country Roads
yeah so we we've gone from Full like you
know future Tech to back to the stone
ages okay because we we we have a group
of five people in this car where we know
we're 15 minutes away from this really
banging Farm party that everyone in like
the town is going to
but we don't know how to get there and
so we kind of just
choose right
and we uh we drive for about it's like a
visual mode we are playing a visual
novel we basically just we may we we
basically like we we basically drive
around we waste an hour and a half
driving around every little country road
we can find until we find a road that
resembles the road name of the address
that we're right takes us an entire in
an hour and a half to find we have no
idea where we are we probably thinking
back we probably should have gotten lost
and uh not known how to get that get
back because they're real [__] stupid
teenagers
um but yeah that was simultaneously the
moment I figured out the potential of
smartphones uh and the limitations of
Technology when uh when you don't have
the right infrastructure it just
reminded me of like this memory I had of
in my mom's car when I was growing up in
the in the back of the driver's seat you
know how there's usually like a pocket
for like putting like you know stuff and
I don't think cars today normally have
this yeah but um in this pocket I
remember when I was like really little
there was this book of the entire map of
the Sydney area right and it was just
this giant like [__] encyclopedia
yeah again it's like you'd have to like
flick through being like all right
address
like under the car like just being like
all right uh turn left here I think
this is like and then now it's just like
yeah it's just all on your phone now
it's so much better I I am completely
content with giving Google uh and
letting it be my Overlord and having all
my data uh for the convenience that it
gives me yeah I'm like yeah sure just
take all my information dude I I'm not
going back to that I also I I mean I
don't know if you guys feel this way but
I forget so much and I realized how much
I do forget because I I turned this on
and I know people are like why would you
do this you know the thing where I can
like keep track of where you've been
yeah and a lot of people like I don't
want to [__] storing where you've
been invading your privacy and I'm like
yeah it's fine but like I already
[__] live so [__] publicly anyway
I don't give a [__] yeah I forget so
much and that that thing tell me where
I've been is super helpful for me
figuring out where I was and what I did
on certain days so I was like man when
was the last time we hung out I'm like I
don't know I know
hmm dude we went here we went here we
weren't here I remember this night now
like I can't remember it like I can't
remember anything before and then when I
remember where I've been it like all
unlocks the memory stream yeah and it's
so weird because I feel like man is my
brain just holding on to a bunch of
[__] useless memories I can't access
oh definitely unless something like
triggers it open absolutely that's just
unfortunately how memory works is way
better it's way better to have likes if
something is there to jerk your memory
or something then it's way better it's
way more efficient than just trying to
grasp it from yeah like you've ever had
like moments where you've like smelt
something and it like triggers a memory
from way back I have that every time I
smell a campfire like every time when
you smell like the smoke of a fire yeah
it just reminds me of like this one
camping trip I went on when I was like
seven years old with my dad and like I
can perfectly Vision everything at that
moment yeah but until I smelt that smoke
it was just completely forgotten in my
head huh and I'm like why is that
that's so weird and it's only with
specific smells as well I don't know why
well it's not just that it's a state of
mind as well yeah I mean have I talked
about this but like if you do something
when you're drunk and then you forget
about it uh
like you'll if you're in that same state
of mind you're more likely to be able to
remember that thing you've forgotten
because it happens all of the [__]
time with Sydney I'm gonna tell you this
right now there is there are a lot of
times where Sydney misplaces a certain
item we look yeah we like turn the
entire Place upside down looking for
this item that she's lost and every
[__] time next time she's drunk she's
like I remember I put it
and I'm just like get drunk again
quickly yeah all right see they've got
this bowl of vodka okay we're gonna find
this thing right now we're gonna find a
house
man I I feel like I forget things so
much more now than I did like five years
ago I don't know what that if that's a
bad Omen I think it's just because
you're doing more stuff right I think
I'm doing a lot more stuff I've got a
lot more on my plate but like I'm so
forgetful I place things down like I I
have these uh like running headphones I
lose them all the [__] time because
they're like my life yeah I'm right like
and then everyone to sign a video HD I'm
like no no
everyone wants to diagnose me with ADHD
every goddamn weed yeah I'm like I I
don't have a hard time focusing I just
forget things
um yeah and it's like I'm like man I
swear I wasn't like this before why am I
forgetting things now I mean it's like a
battle you're like I'm gonna get him old
am I becoming 80 years old starting uh I
think I think it's a mixture of things
because we we touched on this before uh
but I do feel the general attention span
of the entire human race is just getting
smaller and smaller because because of
the internet you mentioned the Netflix
thing like a few podcasts ago and I had
this thing
um recently where I was going through
like YouTube shorts and if it even
buffers for like a millisecond I'm like
no
it buffers for just like you see that
spinning wheel from milliseconds yeah
and like no I didn't even go to the next
one I just closed the app
I'm like maybe this is the app telling
me that's enough about it maybe you
should go do something productive yeah
either I just turn off the app or I go
to the next video immediately if I see
that yeah yeah holy [__] what is wrong
with my brain right yeah man and it's
like you know it wasn't even like 10 20
years ago where I'd be like oh I have to
wait three hours for this movie yeah
yeah easy no worries I'll just go do
something else yes yeah I just feel like
all this all this technology and stuff
and I was just remember us right now
saying this does feel like there's like
weird side effects that we don't really
understand to a lot of the being being
on all the time and I'm like man I don't
know what it is but it feels like
something's weird yeah we're in this
doomsday-esque situation yeah I don't
know why I'm like I'm sure I'll be right
though Google Maps tells me where I was
it's like do you ever get that thing of
like you know I'm sure this has come
with everyone nowadays but like if
you're like does anyone's dick it
doesn't work
yeah you just like take a picture
no it's almost like the water droplet on
the phone meme it's like you hate it
when the water drops on your phone text
all your friends that you're gay
no but it's like you know I'm sure like
you know whenever anyone goes to take a
[__] you're just like all right pulling
out my phone you know they're checking
out some [__] while I take a [__] you
know it's common thing nowadays but like
have you ever had those moments where
you go into the toilet maybe you're
busting for sure and you're prayer
Noggin and you're like all right I've
got no time I've got to run in right now
and you sit down and you realize you've
left your phone in another room and
you're like
[__] what now what do I do I try and
enjoy the [__] that just that just makes
me think yeah I think what did what did
I do before
generally I'm like thinking back because
I had a good 13 14 years of my life
without a mobile phone I must have done
something while I [__] but I can't for
the life of her you might remember what
I did I did yeah I think we used to
think about stuff way more than we do
now because like I think it's really
easy to not have to think about stuff
yeah because you can always just open up
Twitter you can always be consuming
right and it's kind of weird because
then you have those moments where you
are forced to maybe sit there and just
think you're like wow this is a strange
sensation that I have to do this and
like yeah that's concerning that's like
a thing right yeah like it's gotten to
the point now where like recently I
can't even shower without a YouTube
video playing in the background now like
I I put on like some audio yeah like I I
know Beth and I was watching a YouTube
video but I'm like that's yeah but even
if it's a share I'm like I got enough
time to like watch a video while I
shower you know maybe like five showers
my last sacred place where I can think
that's why it takes so long in the
shower man
that's my last secret I think honestly
my favorite thing about the Onsen is
that I don't get anything from the
outside world that's true it's like one
hour where all I do is bathe and think
and chill maybe talk to some friends but
yeah a lot of the times it's just me the
bath maybe the sauna and I just I just
think man I just think about what do you
think about life that man stage across
the room I'm like it's like damn it it's
bigger than mine
I don't know it's weird
um yeah it's almost uncomfortable I
think and it's it's concerning
comfortable being by yourself I think
it's strange because like if you're a
kid now maybe you never even have to
think about anything yeah you can just
constantly be consuming or preoccupied
yeah and what does that do to your brain
I have no idea